you know I knew that you had tattoos and
I've obviously seen pictures of you but
in person you you have a lot of tattoos
how many tattoos do you have you know if
I was to count them individually H time
I got them maybe 60 but when they get
close enough together they start to
become one yes you like a sleeve good
that was really like 17 different
tattoos but now I can just say to you
know the big studio heads it's just
three tattoos guys like it's just this
is three I can cover that up like easy I
can play I can play Emily Dickinson this
I just covered this up yeah we're fine
there's like nothing I can't do
it's funny you've been getting a
speaking of your appearance you're
obviously very striking very beautiful
you get a lot of comparisons to people
say you look exactly like Justin Bieber
and how do you feel about that you know
I hear that he gets asked a lot if he is
reviewers and yeah it must be very
frustrating you know you can relate
because you look like a mixture of like
tilda swinton yes I do
Meryl Streep yes and like joel edgerton
yeah I do you would be like their love
child if three if even I like that it's
three and two or women that's what I
like you through one guy in there I just
just push it up just a little bit for me
I look like Dame Judi Dench I look like
Betty White